[Música]
diferentes países de occidente anuncian
la retirada de sus connacionales de
kabul en afganistán en medio del avance
del grupo talibán son ya 18 capitales
provinciales en manos de los insurgentes
canadá finlandia noruega dinamarca
francia alemania y reino unido- están
evacuando a su personal diplomático
hoy inician en mexico los diálogos entre
la oposición y el gobierno venezolano la
oposición intenta garantizar su
participación en un proceso de
elecciones libres y transparentes
mientras maduro pide como eje central
que levanten las sanciones mientras
busca legitimidad internacional
desde hoy el periódico la prensa de
nicaragua no circula más en su versión
impresa los insumos para hacerlo siguen
bloqueados por el gobierno de daniel
ortega la sociedad interamericana de
prensa calificó de ozil y anti libertad
de prensa lo sucedido con el diario más
antiguo de ese país
muy buena tarde gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 cerrado blanco
como siempre un gusto seguirlos
acompañando en afganistán ya son más de
18 las 34 capitales de provincia
capturadas por el talibán un avance
vertiginoso en pocas semanas que han
roto las previsiones internacionales
ante ellos países como eeuu van a
retirar a sus conciudadanos dinamarca y
noruega cierran sus embajadas y francia
pide a sus ciudadanos que abandonen
afganistán mientras tanto la otan
advierte que no reconocerá al talibán si
toman el país por la fuerza informados
muñoz
después de 20 años de intervención
internacional militar en afganistán la
otan pide que los países mantengan su
presencia diplomática para apoyar el
gobierno afgano sin embargo ante el
avance del talibán también crece el
cierre de embajadas o su reducción al
mínimo de la operación como alemania
félix reduciremos el personal de la
embajada alemana en kabul a el mínimo
absoluto necesario desde el punto de
vista operativo en los próximos días
google tren diga absoluto mínimo mujer
uds llevan una medida de evacuación
desesperada cuando los insurgentes se
encuentran apenas 100 kilómetros de
kabul ante ello las fuerzas armadas
occidentales están sacando a sus
ciudadanos del país
eeuu va a utilizar a 3.000 soldados para
la retirada mientras que australia
trabaja para evacuar a todos sus
ciudadanos
singapur cerramos nuestra embajada en
kabul el 28 de mayo y devolvimos a los
diplomáticos no residentes en afganistán
y ahora estamos repatriando a aquellos
que llevan trabajando con nosotros desde
hace tiempo y de afe sound son en este
contexto las naciones unidas advierten
de la gravedad de conflictos axilar y el
conflicto se ha acelerado mucho más
rápido de lo pensado y la situación
tiene todas las características de una
catástrofe humanitaria
y en plena crisis también se empiezan a
buscar los culpables voces de reino
unidos señalan a la retirada de las
tropas estadounidenses
este es un gran error y un gran error
estratégico de eeuu y de sus aliados
en pocas semanas el talibán ha
recuperado el terreno perdido en 20 años
y mientras la comunidad internacional
huye de la posible captura de kabul
los locales tratan de conseguir una visa
extranjera o en la mayoría de casos
cruzar la frontera un país vecino
veamos a continuación un mapa de cuáles
son las ciudades bajo el control talibán
cómo vamos a ver kandahar las carga y
feroz coj fueron las últimas ciudades
tomadas por los insurgentes kandahar ha
sido considerada como la capital
histórica del país ya que en el pasado
sirvió durante siglos como el centro del
poder en afganistán según acnur el
balance de talibán y el avance talibán
ha dejado al menos unos 250.000
desplazados desde su inicio en el mes de
mayo el 80 por ciento de ellos mujeres y
niños
y el costo humano de las hostilidades en
espiral es inmenso la misión de
asistencia de las naciones unidas
advirtió que sin una reducción
significativa de la violencia afganistán
está en camino de presenciar el mayor
número de víctimas civiles documentadas
en un solo año desde que comenzaron los
registros de la onu hoy viernes 13 de
agosto con noruega méxico y rusia como
observadores inician la ciudad de mexico
un nuevo intento de negociaciones entre
el gobierno de venezuela y sectores de
la oposición tras una crisis política
continua durante casi dos décadas la
oposición intenta garantizar su
participación en un proceso de
elecciones libres y transparentes
mientras que nicolás maduro pide que se
levanten las sanciones internacionales
así como la legitimidad en el exterior
conectamos con nuestro corresponsal en
ciudad de méxico mario carbonell mario
muy buen día que podemos esperar en
estas negociaciones y que detalles hay
del primer día
hola pues en este primer día de tres que
se espera que se desarrollen estas
pláticas los objetivos finales ya los
mencionados son garantías de elecciones
libres por parte de la oposición y que
se levanten las sanciones por parte del
gobierno de maduro esas son las
expectativas pero que se espera para el
día de hoy concretamente se espera la
firma de un memorándum de entendimiento
que fije tres puntos el primero las
reglas acordar las reglas del proceso
esta es la metodología de estas
negociaciones el segundo es definir en
específico los puntos que se van a
abordar es decir si se va a hablar
únicamente de política o también de
otros asuntos como la economía y el
tercero es definir la agenda de las
reuniones futuras es decir un cronograma
para las pláticas que tendrán lugar
después de estos tres días acá en méxico
en las negociaciones están por comenzar
será a las 4 30 cuando den inicio y pues
ya están definidos los representantes
tanto de la oposición como por parte del
gobierno
las maduro
mario gracias y justo hoy en su país se
conmemora la caída del imperio mexica
conocido como civilización azteca una fe
mérida ahora rebautizada como de
resistencia indígena que insiste en la
importancia de pedir perdón por los
agravios cometidos por los pueblos a los
pueblos originarios el 13 de agosto de
1521 los colonizadores españoles tomaron
la capital tenochtitlán a manos de los
grupos de indígenas enfrentados con el
poder azteca en lo que históricamente se
describe como una conquista sangrienta y
brutal el aniversario ha dado lugar a
distintas reivindicaciones de la cultura
originaria de investigaciones sobre los
principales episodios de la colonización
española
se cumplen 500 años de la caída del
imperio azteca tras 75 días de sitio el
13 de agosto de 1521 los españoles
guiados por hernán cortez tomaron
brutalmente la capital del imperio
méxico-tenochtitlan la conquista fue
posible por la alianza de los colonos
hispánicos con pueblos indígenas
confrontados a los aztecas los días
previos el aniversario en ciudad de
mexico grupos de defensa de la cultura
prehispánica conmemoraron la resistencia
de sus raíces a través de siglos de
presiones pues me siento orgullosa
porque estamos a 500 años recordando no
la caída estamos recordando el
resurgimiento de nuestras raíces que son
muy profundas raíces que penetran el
zócalo la plaza principal de ciudad de
méxico que fue levantada sobre el centro
político y religioso de tenochtitlan
nuestra cultura la escribieron los
vencedores entonces esos vencedores
dejaron escrito mediante su pensamiento
su palabra porque está en español
su idea entonces está todo alterado
tergiversado distorsionado con el
objetivo de repensar la historia un
grupo de investigadores de la unam
desarrolló el videojuego japan sobre la
historia de los tlaxcaltecas uno de los
pueblos mesoamericanos que participó
junto a los españoles en el derribo del
imperio azteca hay diferentes versiones
sobre esta historia esta es una más la
de los tlaxcaltecas la del pueblo atrás
caltech a que se erigió como vencedor de
los de las guerras y las alianzas de
conquista y así lo expresaba en
documentos como el lienzo de tlaxcala
500 años después documentos como el
lienzo de tlaxcala son un túnel del
tiempo a la colonización española
la prensa el principal diario de
nicaragua el más antiguo del país no
tiene desde hoy su circulación impresa
porque se quedó sin insumos el gobierno
daniel ortega tiene retenido el papel
para poder imprimirlo la sociedad
interamericana de prensa calificó el
hecho de hostil y anti libertad de
prensa y al retoque del gobierno no ha
respondido varias cartas y mensajes
enviados por los directivos del medio de
comunicación esta mañana conversamos con
alberto cortez e ramos catedrático
politólogo de la universidad de costa
rica conductor del libro anhelos de un
nuevo horizonte aportes para una
nicaragua democrática sobre cuál es el
panorama de los medios de comunicación
en ese país tras esta escalada de
represión en nicaragua esto fue lo que
nos dijo
definitivamente este es un hecho más que
evidencia a la deriva autoritaria que
tiene este gobierno efectivamente
la pareja presidencial viene conculcando
una serie de derechos políticos básicos
fundamentales para la convivencia
democrática ha encarcelado periodistas
también tiene una legislación que
básicamente es
represiva y persecutoria de el
periodismo y de los periodistas y este
es digamos un
aporte más en la línea de conculcar la
libertad de expresión en nicaragua y eso
abona a un clima político
autoritario y represivo que impide la
realización de una salida democrática
político democrática en las elecciones
que vienen recuerdo que están a pocos
meses de hacer las elecciones en
noviembre
hablemos ahora en la pandemia cuba
registra un promedio de 8.000 casos
diarios de kobe 19 la isla enfrenta un
brote de coronavirus por la variante
delta que ha gustado a su sistema a su
sistema de salud para enfrentar el virus
cientos de médicos regresaron a la isla
cubanos en la diáspora envían
medicamentos para aplicar para aplacar
la escasez y el presidente díaz canel
llamó al compromiso para superar este
pico pandémico el informes de carolina
los ha león
cuba sufre un pico pandémico por la
variante delta con un incremento de
miles de casos diarios desde semanas a
pesar de contar con un plan de
vacunación que ya inmunizó a más del 60%
de la población y dos vacunas producidas
localmente soberana y abdalá el sistema
de salud cubano se encuentra sobrepasado
un bastante fallecido una institución y
que tenemos una sola morgue que tenemos
un solo crematorio y que son muchos
fallecidos el presidente de cuba miguel
díaz-canel mencionó los esfuerzos que se
realizan para enfrentar la pandemia y
pidió hacer un esfuerzo a la población
les pido comprensión compromiso y
pensamiento sobre todo para en el menor
tiempo posible estar en las condiciones
para sobrepasar este pico pandémico que
podemos vencer señal de la agudeza de la
situación cientos de doctores cubanos
que se encontraban en misiones en
diferentes países regresaron a la isla
para brindar apoyo en hospitales si bien
cuba mantuvo los casos de kobe bajo
control durante el primer año de la
pandemia la variante delta cambió esta
situación
los casos que surgen a partir de la de
la cepa delta que es una cepa más
expansiva de una cepa más
agresiva indiscutiblemente que nos está
creando situaciones complejas a nivel de
a nivel hospitalario
también desde el extranjero llegan
medicamentos para aliviar la escasez de
productos de salud muestra de la
solidaridad de la diáspora cubana el
gobierno cubano que enfrente el pico
pandémico con un embargo de eeuu y en
temporada de huracanes llamó al personal
de salud a acelerar los procesos de
vacunación suministros de oxígeno y
medicamentos
cambiamos ahora información y también de
continente en corea del sur el
vicepresidente de samsung lee jong fue
indultado este viernes y puesto en
libertad condicional después de 207 días
en prisión por cargos de corrupción los
pedidos para su excarcelación desde
sectores de la política la población y
el mundo empresarial venían en aumento
en medio de preocupaciones en torno a la
falta de decisiones estratégicas en el
que es el mayor conglomerado del país
más en el siguiente informe
libre pero bajo una nube de polémica el
vicepresidente de samsung lee jae yong
fue excarcelado después de haber
completado año y medio detrás de las
rejas por entregar sobornos entre otros
delitos de corrupción relacionados con
el escándalo que terminó en la salida
del anterior gobierno de corea del sur
he causado muchos problemas entre la
gente lo lamento profundamente
estoy escuchando los problemas las
críticas las preocupaciones y las altas
expectativas por mí voy a trabajar duro
uno de los hombres más ricos del mundo
con 53 años fue encarcelado en un primer
momento en 2017 antes de ser liberado
por una apelación la corte suprema del
país ordenó entonces repetir el juicio
que terminó en su regreso a prisión en
enero de este año haya sido declarado
culpable de sobornar a la mano derecha
de la expresidenta pajín view quien
también terminó en la cárcel después de
crecientes llamados de las grandes
empresas para restituir el liderazgo de
sancho en el medio de la pandemia el
ministerio de justicia anunció este
lunes su indulto que supone una
reducción de dos años y medio sobre su
condena esta liberación va en línea con
la larga tradición en corea del sur de
indultar a líderes empresariales
encarcelados por corrupción y evasión
fiscal y otros temas financieros aunque
el nieto del fundador de samsung
permanece en un proceso en torno a
manipulación de acciones ahora su camino
se abre para volver a tomar el control
de la empresa familiar más grande de la
nación
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france24 feliz fin de
semana para todos hasta pronto
[Música]
al abrirlo
estoy viendo que ustedes
[Música]
entre ellos y dice el artículo
[Aplausos]
el sitio es muy distinto
[Música]